you talked about New York's favorite
billionaires you're now on that list
would you want to get into government I
mean you talk about this from a very
passionate place I'm on a lot of Lissa I
own deserve to be on would you like to
get into government you know something I
you know I have a great job and the job
has Rick you know has with it a lot of
interaction with terrific people and a
lot of you know you know a lot of
influence and a lot of you know
participation in the forces that are
helping to shape the economy and so I
love that can you get that same
satisfaction from government I think
Mike you know Mike has been successful
in both areas and I bet you he's had a
bitter better influence obviously
through his position in government and
when I think back you know just small
thing and just you know changing the
rules on smoking I mean how many lives
were saved by that and people don't talk
about that I think I think would be you
know I think would be an attractive
thing to do but a very unattractive
place to get to